vingt-cinq ans d'existence pour pégase
l'association de l'estaca spécialisée
dans les activités scientifiques pour
enfants à célébrer son anniversaire
étudiant à l'école d'ingénieurs entre
2001 et 2003 eugène était engagée dans
l'association
à 39 ans il est aujourd'hui manager de
projet les souvenirs que j'ai c'est va
déjà l'émerveillement des enfants
pouvoir ouvrir un champ du possible sur
des sciences sur la vie du quotidien
comprendre le fonctionnement de choses
extrêmement complexe les étudiants
interviennent les jeudis après midi dans
des classes d'écoles primaires
expérience ateliers de construction de
maquettes des animations ludiques pour
éveiller les enfants aux sciences
dans l'interview ci donc à l'hôpital
pédiatrique de bullion dans des classes
d'enfants malades
on a aussi un nouveau projet cette année
donc avec des lycées techniques donc à
la celle saint cloud et attrapes pour
toujours pareil la pédagogie la proche
des sciences autre projet des activités
menées au sénégal organisé au début des
années 2000 ce voyage humanitaire permet
de fournir du matériel scientifique est
de faire découvrir des expériences aux
écoliers sénégalais des compétences
importantes pour les futurs ingénieurs
aujourd'hui en fait quand on interroge
un
recruteur les industriels qui vont
recruter nos jeunes ingénieurs ils nous
disent clairement qu'ils attendent
autant des connaissances un savoir faire
et un savoir être et dans le savoir être
il ya ces compétences de pédagogie mise
en place en début d'année des animations
sont dorénavant menée à l'hôpital
pédiatrique de bullion